yeah one one question i wanted to ask  uh  what if what do you think about the the  play of your one known  like one definitely known opponent if  you decide to play next year  the one person you know you will be  facing what do you think of him  that was so cryptic a question that's  eric  or  arigaisi i think no i regard the known  eye we're talking about this tournament  yeah this tournament yeah if you if you  choose to play this tournament next year  yeah as a winner  yeah he's kind of uh  yeah he's kind of cooled off the last um  last couple of rounds but he's  ah he's really strong uh i mean  as i said before he's by far the best  player in  in the challengers  um  [Music]  and  [Music]  he's taking huge  strides  um  recently but he's  there really isn't that much to  distinguish his play from from that of  most players of the  of the masters group he's um  i think  he's gonna  he's gonna play and he's gonna belong  next year that's uh  would be my prediction